that protests in New York is in response
to Governor Andrew Cuomo's announcement
that he's creating a blacklist of any
group promoting BDS the boycott
divestment and sanctions movement
targeting Israel any group on that list
will lose state funding the BDS movement
has gained momentum recently and so have
the efforts to defeat it we are against
the BDS movement and it's very simple if
you boycott against Israel New York will
boycott you Bono acted unilaterally by
signing an executive action and
bypassing the New York State Legislature
which failed to pass a similar bill BDS
is a global campaign born out of a call
from Palestinian civil society in 2005
the goal is to pressure Israel to comply
with international law and respect
Palestinian human rights its supporters
say BDS follows a long tradition of
nonviolent movements throughout history
that brought about social change
the fight for BDS has largely been on
college campuses across the u.s. but
more recently the fight has moved from
college campuses to state legislatures
more than 20 states have either passed
or are considering legislation similar
to New York's unprecedented executive
order all with the intention of
silencing opposition to the Israeli
occupation but is any of this even legal
advocates argue anti BDS legislation is
unconstitutional because participation
in political boycotts is protected under
the First Amendment and there's legal
precedent a 1982 Supreme Court case
concerning the n-double-a-cp
found that states could not prohibit
peaceful political activity like
boycotts activists say New York's
executive order will be challenged in
court
the ACLU slammed the action calling it
an affront to free expression but in the
meantime the BDS movement is growing
claiming victories like British security
firm g4s withdrawing from doing business
in Israel last year under pressure from
activists and that has Israel's
government worried last year Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
allocated 25 million dollars to set up a
government agency dedicated fully to
fighting the movement back in the US the
powerful pro-israel lobby AIPAC has made
fighting BDS
a major priority it didn't surprise many
to see a pack officials standing beside
Governor Cuomo as he signed the
executive order Las Vegas billionaire
Sheldon Adelson has also poured in
millions of dollars in the anti BDS push
and we do see this I have to say as a
response for the growing power of the
BDS movement as more and more people are
recognizing that the rights of
Palestinians are a human rights issue
and that we in the United States have a
lot of responsibility for that so is New
York's attack on BDS a setback or will
it only further galvanized the movement